her new book is called double puppy
trouble it teaches four to seven year
olds about doubling numbers danica
mckellar joins us now good morning good
to see you hey good morning great to see
you too
so this book's amazing
i have it right here um and it teaches
kids young kids about how to double and
it uses these little cute puppies what
gave you the idea to write this
i want math to be as approachable and
fun for kids as possible i've been doing
it for years like you said with all my
books
i can't think of anything more fun and
approachable than puppies
so
yeah a book like this helps kids from a
very young age make this really fun
association with numbers especially as
the numbers get big and what this math
book does is it's not really a math book
it sneaks math in it's kind of like
putting vegetables in brownies you know
it's 101 domination
you know with a little math in it so
kids get to see this fun adventure where
these puppies get out of control and
this little girl who finds this magical
stick is doubling these puppies that
gets out of control
she you know it ultimately is a story of
less is more having gratitude so there's
a lot of emotional intelligence in it as
well but hey i love sneaking those math
concepts in there to help kids
let go of some of this math anxiety that
we're seeing it more and more um it's
just it's my joy to be able to present
this kind of thing to kids
well so i don't know about my co-host
but i'm terrible at math and part of it
is because i was very i was terrorized
by math and so the notion of trying to
make it accessible and to make it fun
for kids at an early age because i do
believe that my fear of math started
when i was very very young like trying
to conceptualize right these these
concepts yeah i'm with vlad too danica
thank you i'm with vlad too about i
don't think i'm good in math but it's
because we keep telling ourselves that
we're bad and mad right but i really am
bad in math let's just call it with math
wasn't fun when we were
exactly fun yes but now we can
permission to make it fun i have all
these books at mckellarmath.com you get
a big slider button so depending on your
kids age i can tell you which book is
best i've got fun picture books like
this i've got books that teach math
concepts all the way up through high
school geometry it's really my mission
to empower kids to have and and to
garner and and develop that confidence
that comes from feeling smart and and
one of the great ways to do that is to
become good at math and you can become
good at math you're not born with one
math level or ability we're not stuck
there it is absolutely possible to yeah
to change break those patterns and break
those um the cycles where parents so
parents out there don't tell your kids
you weren't good at math try to avoid
the topic introduced into books like
this spend time with your kids bonding
over reading i mean it's such a
wonderful thing anyway and why not do it
sneaking in a little math
yeah i think you make such a good point
you know most of us fell in love with
you danica's winnie cooper i love that
show just looking at that clip brought
back memories but where does your
passion and your love of math come from
you were an actress as a young girl
where did you make the switch where does
it what was it about numbers and math
that you thought this is cool
you know it was it was really in college
i mean i've always loved a good
challenge but in college um i the wonder
years had just ended and becoming a math
major was something i wasn't expecting
to do but i was so attracted to how my
brain felt and how valuable i felt for
something that had nothing to do with
superficiality and you don't have to
have been a child actress to struggle
with identity and
and your value so i knew that i could
give this to other kids and teenagers as
well through my books making it fun i'm
an entertaining entertainer and i love
making making math entertaining so
that's kind of my that's my thing i like
to make math entertaining inapproachable
absolutely
and i want to empower other kids
especially girls but all kids as well i
like that is so important um as gail
mentioned you started wonder years when
you were 12
what advice would you go back and give
your younger self and i know there's
young kids that are starting off their
tv and movies career movie careers
watching right now so they are listening
to this advice
yes well uh it's advice that luckily i
didn't need and that is do something
else also
because the acting business is very um
fickle and although i am still acting
today in fact i've got i'll be doing a
christmas movie for a great american
family a new channel uh it's a lot of
fun i did domino masters but let me tell
you something having my math books
is such um it's it's so wonderful for me
it's such a stable core also i know i'm
spreading love and happiness and
intelligence into the world which is so
wonderful but if you're going to pursue
acting as a child do something else too
something that you have a little more
control over
well here's some simple math for
everybody you plus any project equals
success danica mckellar thank you so
much for joining us double puppy trouble
is on sale now i like the title too
that's right